I am going to speak to you today about
yet another framework author dot mail oh
shoot
okay I guess I somehow I'm getting my
email on this presentation computer boy
half here let's see I got an email
message of comparison I it's the weekly
JavaScript JavaScript weekly newsletter
I'd like to get this thing it tells me
what's happening in the JavaScript world
every week it's just a collection of
links I would recommend checking it out
let's take a look at this week's email
we've had a concise comparison of
JavaScript web frameworks an eleven part
series comparing really amber dojo view
react an angular reaches the conclusion
by looking at the pros and cons of each
oh I guess I better read that because I
haven't used every single one of those
and I really need to keep up with the
industry right I should probably read
that eleven part and blog post what's
next on here a look at angular code
alongside view code ooh yeah I haven't
really considered the the pros and cons
of both of those I got to read that
what's next in this email react
spreadsheet grid and Excel like react
and Excel like grid component ooh yeah I
kind of maybe have a project or two
where I could use an embedded Excel
thing but I'm not using react for those
does that mean I need to you learn react
so that I can use it for this and use
this component what else is in this
email getting kind of stressed out
developing real-time apps with meteor oh
yeah I do kind of want to add a
real-time thing to my latest project but
I haven't used meteor do I need to learn
it for this I haven't learned that
either
what's next year passing data between
routes and a few JSF ah okay I'm getting
super stressed out what do i do what do
I do
okay sorry for that interruption close
my email let's get back to the talk
but you know come to think of it this is
the dot J s conference anything can
happen so why don't I just scrap the
topic and maybe talk about something
else that I was just inspired by reading
that this week in JavaScript email let's
talk about the case against frameworks
speaking as a framework author myself so
much of the time if you're keeping up
with the industry so to speak reading
websites like hacker news reddit getting
these sort of this week in JavaScript
emails just checking Twitter it's like
you're on a treadmill right you're
constantly getting assaulted by the the
latest news about all these frameworks
it's like they're these warplanes and
here comes reacts sweeping in with some
latest developments that you definitely
need to know about oh and here's Vijay s
and everyone's talking about that now so
oh maybe that means I need to learn that
too do I need to how do I prioritize
this what the heck is going on I'm gonna
go crazy
has anyone seen this excellent blog post
from last year yeah make some noise if
you did ok yeah ok good I I highly
highly recommend checking this blog post
out even though it's more than a year
old how it feels to learn JavaScript in
2016 if anything 2017 has gotten worse
and in case you haven't seen this post
it's a fantastic parity conversation
between two web developers where one of
them is asking very honest questions
like oh so how do I do this on a web
page how do i display additive how do I
update it with data and this this
so-called professional developer who's
been keeping up on the industry is
saying oh yeah you gotta do this
framework gotta do this and then you
gotta cross compile this and got to do
babble on this and got to do this in
this oh and don't forget this oh and
some parts yeah this one kinda isn't
cool anymore so don't use that and by
the end of this blog post you get this
amazing sense of being overwhelmed and
stress at everything you need to know
just to do some relatively basic stuff
displaying things on a webpage and
getting them to to be interactive why is
this so complicated I think there are
some simple reasons and there's some
more cynical reasons the simple reasons
are we're in a relatively young industry
a lot of standards and best practices
are still actively being figured out it
is inherently a complicated problem of
doing the front-end code - a web app
there's a lot of moving parts many many
things can go wrong and why not let the
experts at Facebook or Google tell us
what to do right then there's some more
cynical reasons I like the suggestion by
PPK Peter Paul aqaq a longtime
JavaScript developer that front-end
programmers have been criticized as
being front-end programmers there just
you know a bunch of noobs for so long
that now front-end programmers are sort
of overcompensating by making some super
over engineered stuff just to say hey
I'm a computer scientist - and then
there's another cynical reason which is
that companies like Facebook and Google
who are promoting these frameworks do
have an incentive to get mindshare so
that you know it's better for their
companies if people use the technologies
that they made sort of increases the
reputation and you know these are good
reasons bad reasons this is there's no
right or wrong answer but let's jump
into a specific app that I've been
working on for just over five years now
it's called sound slice and it is music
education software all web based I don't
believe in native apps if I can avoid it
and the idea is that you learn music
better if you can see a video and cease
the sync music notation at the same time
so you can press play
and see see the notes that are being
played you can do things like highlight
on the notation and it'll loop just that
section of the audio and if it's super
fast like this you can slow it down
without changing the pitch so you can
really dig into the tune so this is
obviously very JavaScript heavy another
cool thing about it is that the music
notation is actually rendered right in
the client and you probably don't know
this but music notation is literally
centuries worth of edge cases it's like
in 1820 this publisher in Germany
decided to use this particular squiggly
mark in this weird musical situation so
I actually had to implement a music
rendering engine in JavaScript so that
lets you do stuff like make the notation
changeable on the fly so you can change
the browser with it it's a responsive it
you can up okay I don't want to just hit
my stuff but I wanted to give you a
sense of the kinds of things that I'm
doing just to establish some credibility
so so this is this is all Java male oh
no I've got another email who's it from
Jay s developer what does it say Adrian
I love love love sound slice what job -
what JavaScript framework do you use
from Jay s developer ah you know what I
get this question all the time whenever
I'm at a meet-up or something or or meet
someone who's a developer ooh that's
cool what JavaScript framework does this
use the answer is it doesn't use one and
I'm fine I'm still alive
have a happy life in fact possibly even
happier then so I'm gonna tell you I'm
gonna give you a few reasons why I've
gone down this road number one if you
haven't seen this site vanilla - Jas com
it's fantastic it's my favorite
javascript framework especially the
deployment instructions was through
fantastic to deploy you actually just
delete that line and and what does it
say this framework is so popular that
browsers have been automatically loading
it for over a decade
it comes pre-installed in Chrome and
Firefox and all these little old
browsers - yeah but the the start of
this philosophy for me came about way
back in the year 2002 I was living in
this small town in the middle of America
called Lawrence Kansas to be fair it's
probably the the Paris of Kansas it's a
reasonably cool town and I was working
as a web developer at a newspaper and
newspapers are very very fast-paced
environments and my boss would
constantly be assigning me programming
tasks and web development tasks that
needed to be done that day like oh this
breaking news event happened make a web
app boom do it in three hours
so sort of out of necessity me and my
colleague Simon Wilson started
developing some tools that let us do
that without you know wanting to quit
and go work somewhere else and we
eventually rolled those into something
that we ended up open sourcing and was
called Django that was open sourced in
2005 it's not JavaScript but it's Python
it's Python but bear with me the almost
immediately after it was open sourced we
started getting all sorts of requests
and early one was internationalization
and localization of course that makes
sense
some people from Holland and Germany
contributed code that would add a whole
abstraction layer of
internationalization for our framework
and even though we were in the Paris of
Kansas it's it's not a very cosmopolitan
place so we really had no need for this
when we originally made these tools but
of course the more people that use your
thing the more needs there are so people
want you to expand the scope of your
framework over the years people demanded
more and more and more and more features
at the time as some of you who have open
source projects of some level of
popularity realized that it becomes like
a second full-time job and that was
certainly the case for me for about
three or four years of my life
constantly responding to tickets and
fixing bugs and over it's time if you
were to plot the bugs and issues that I
actually personally was affected by you
you would see that going way way down
and after a few years I was just fixing
bugs and adding features for for people
at fixing bugs that I would never
encounter myself and adding features
that I would never use myself so I
started I began thinking of frameworks
as sort of these these big blobs that
had to cater to every single use case
it's sort of this vicious cycle the more
popular something gets the more users it
has and therefore the more demand there
is for new features and the more
features it gets the more user it has so
sort of just keeps on expanding I
actually like to think of it as what
they say about sleeping with someone
when you sleep with someone you're
actually sleeping with everybody else
that that person has ever slept with
when you use the framework you're you're
taking all of the the cruft and stuff
that other other users have wanted oh
yeah there was that one guy in Argentina
who had this really weird use case for
his CMS and when you download Django you
get bad hooray
okay so after a few years I decided to
step down as one of the beat
fells of Django partly for that reason
for many reasons is a complicated thing
but that really started to color my my
thinking about frameworks and and
general purpose tools like this so back
to the sound slice thing if I don't use
a framework what do I actually use and
and the answer is there's sort of this
middle ground there's a framework by the
way many of you have probably heard this
definition of what a framework is and
how a difference differs from a library
but just in case you haven't a library
is something that you call from your
code and a framework would be something
that calls your code so there's
something I think in the middle which is
just patterns it's ways of approaching
web development and this I think is that
is a world that isn't explored as much
as it should be there are many sites
that tell you about this framework there
are many sites to tell you about this
library but there aren't more
general-purpose sites that talk about
approaches to making a web app patterns
and sort of first principles I think
that's something that's really missing
lately I've seen several of my friends
who are a longtime web developers just
say enough with this screw it I'm gonna
go into an entirely different career
path or even worse I'm gonna go develop
native apps because at least in native
apps there's the queer story you just
here's the API you don't have to worry
about analysis paralysis and the paradox
of choice and all these different
options and it's really sad because the
the JavaScript front-end world is so
complex where we're really driving
people away and it's not just
established developers it's it's new
developers if I were starting today I'd
be terrified I I take one look at hacker
news or something and and say I what am
I supposed to learn I open up that
JavaScript email and say what a
parison of how many javascript
frameworks so how deep do I need to dig
into all these and what do I need to do
so it I think this is a big problem and
part of the answer came to me when I
studied with my favorite living guitar
player who actually lives you in Paris
and I'm gonna get to see him play while
I'm here so that's great I was studying
with him
Adri I'm one yard is his name and he
said or I was asking him oh how do I
play like you show me that lick and
what's that thing you do over the D
minor 7 and what's that thing and he was
nice for the first bit but then he
started saying you know it's time to
think for yourself come up with your own
ideas do your own thing you jazz
improvisational music is isn't about
copying other people it's about thinking
for yourself and sometimes you may want
to copy and learn from other people but
really it's about being yourself and I
really have have taken that to heart I
think it's super important to think for
yourself so my main message to you is
isn't to stop using frameworks
necessarily it's to keep an open mind if
you're browsing the the latest hot
JavaScript news looking at hacker news
attending a conference where many people
are pitching their own frameworks and
such don't dare do resist the urge to
just feel stressed to learn every single
thing it's totally ok to just use
JavaScript you can do super cool stuff
with it and and it also scales you don't
have to worry about frameworks going out
of fashion or being an unmaintained it's
totally fine so if you think for
yourself
two thumbs up you've got mail oh geez
what oh I got this same thing I'm gonna
unsubscribe
thank you
[Applause]